Tor alert baby look out stay trashy tour
is about to kick in the full swing gang
we're adding cities we're adding shows
tickets are going quick come out and see
us Little Live stand up comedy plus we
pay ayg with the crowd it's a good good
time come and hang with the boys yeah
baby in March we're knocking out
Baltimore Virginia Beach Richmond
Virginia Oklahoma City Dallas Texas
Houston Texas Austin Texas second show
added New Haven Connecticut there's
about two tree tickets left if they're
even available anymore we got Burlington
Vermont Tampa second show out of first
so showed out Dania Beach Florida
Raleigh North Carolina Louisville
Kentucky just added Cleveland and
Columbus get those tickets more cities
coming soon let's party let's do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find it out
they're going to be classy or to just a
big old piece of trash I'm your hostage
Foley coming at you on a beautiful day
we're down here at antuti's basement
she's upstairs taking a nice little nap
okay waiting for that settlement check
to clean I hear it's coming oh it's
gonna be raining cash here soon gang my
co-host is coming at you from right next
to me he is the CEO of Ru garbage she is
an international businessman and he's my
best pal in the whole wide world and I
love him I don't care who knows it give
it up for KJ Kevin James Ryan everybody
what's up gang thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate view
subscribe on iTunes full video of album
YouTube as you know those numbers are
cooking then the greatest God darn
website of all time
www.patreon.com or you garbage baby
check it out it's a good time over there
ooh love that money how about a nice
quick shout out to our producer X Jordan
Air the magic man makes us all look good
works the ones Works tattoos crosses the
t's and dots the eyes give it up for
T-Bone mcgruffins Toby McMullen
everybody what's up dudes I'm so [__]
stoked let's go little royalty in the
building here today gang the long hair
ain't lying because we could not be more
excited to have our incredibly and I
mean incredibly special guest here with
us today for the first time he is a very
funny very successful comedian podcaster
producer writer he is the co-host of the
amazing podcast t-e-s-d and of course he
is one of the creators and stars of the
global Juggernaut sensation sensation
phenomenon that is the Impractical
Jokers do us a favor give us a nice big
round of applause for Mr Brian Quinn
simply known as Q yes very cute thank
you hell of a hype man I think
we really prop you up to knock you down
I was touring because halfway through I
always started being like man I I would
not have agreed to this intro but then
about halfway through that I was like
they're missing credits
good episode of 12 Monkeys man that
character Dale
did you see that episode so I played a
character named Dale in 12 Monkeys and
my buddy Terry who ran 12 Monkeys also
ran MacGyver for a season so he took
Dale and he put Dale in MacGyver no way
the story that starts in the one scene I
have in uh in uh 12 Monkeys yeah where
Dale just got divorced you you catch up
with him on a date a crossover and I and
I give MacGyver the thing that allows
him to get out of the Trap like I give
him like chocolate bar and then
show ran uh Picard he ran so now in
season two Picard Dale comes I have the
same time yeah
you guys [__] you forgot I'm trying
to give you the cool [__] so I had this
one tie that I wore on 12 Monkeys that I
stole from production and I wore that
trash already yeah oh yeah I wore that
tie on uh MacGyver okay and then I wore
the Thai and Picard and the character's
name is Dale so we're calling it The
Dale verse and if you follow each scene
there is a storyline going on and and so
the next show that Terry gets which I
know what it is already I don't think
I'm allowed to say it he writes a small
scene for Dale so we're calling it The
Dale verse that's great that's like the
Adam Sandler verse yeah it's gonna be
this one character over years across uh
all story lines so you know popping up
on General Hospital we'll do anything
Carol's twin brother yeah exactly yeah
hold on an elevator oh man buddy thank
you so much for coming oh man I gotta
tell you Sal uh Sal really pumped this
up a lot of fun here now the pressure's
on us great I didn't know he he all
right back to us he said it's better if
I don't know if like I go in kind of
blind so I didn't really do any research
I was just told it was like a comedy
podcast so I brought like a slide
whistle
there's not much research he's bald and
I'm fat that's about all you need to
know I'm not kidding I bought it
foreign
any time this may come into play slide
whistle out of a drug rug well the drug
works just my fashion Choice man I don't
know he's coming from a fish concert
this guy bringing it back you guys are
telling me you're not instantly jealous
you're not wearing one of these you
[__] know you're jealous you know you
are who left the nitrous tank downstairs
that's [__] it I don't care everybody
watching is like man I wish I had the
bolster I do that's the thing I wish I
had the balls to rock it I'm just
chilled out like that I don't care just
go with the vibe you think I care look
what I'm wearing
[__] you the Beards immaculately trim
though well that is uh they dyed my hair
uh uh they dyed my beard red on
Impractical Jokers okay this whole thing
but part of it was my beard was red and
it's slowly growing back in so it looks
good goes out a little bit yeah look
sharp thank you man give us the back
story give it give us the whole deal
grow up where were you born and raised
well I was born in Brooklyn
Hospital yeah uh uh March 14th 1976.
okay nice uh I was I have an early
memory of my apartment in Brooklyn and
then I moved to Staten Island or was
moved to Staten Island when I was two
and I spent uh basically the rest of my
life on Staten Island nice that's a big
thing for a Brooklyn family is to get to
Staten Island right it used to be I
don't know if it's like that anymore but
yeah when they built the Verrazano
bridge that connected to uh Brooklyn and
Staten Island they called it the guinea
gang plane sure
bikinis like came over and built the
houses and the pizzerias and came over
and that was the Staten Island I grew up
on a very Italian Irish type of uh Place
what'd your mom and dad do my mother uh
she ended up eventually doing the most
most of her her career as a manager for
uh back Statin Island Savings Bank which
okay became Santander which actually
crippled me in terms of like adult
responsibility because when your mom's
in manager of a bank like you don't even
you don't pay attention to check books
and stuff will take care of it yeah
that's true uh and then she retired and
I had a rude awakening but I just
started handling my own finances yeah
that was pretty scary and then my dad
was uh he was a motorman for the MTV MTA
he drove uh subway cars yeah he did that
for about 17 years then he became a
dispatcher uh which is the guy that
calls where the trains goes and stuff
like that so yeah I had a real super
blue collar damn that's old school yeah
it was my sisters I have two brothers I
have an older brother Jimmy younger
brother Danny okay yeah
um
what did we grow up in was it an
apartment single family home what are we
looking at it was a semi-attached uh it
was uh I think when my parents bought it
back in the 70s it was thirty thousand
dollars
um and it's just like a semi-attached
home which I don't if you don't I don't
know what semi you know if people cross
your audience would know but it
basically means a house that's splitting
two sure right it's not connected on
this side but it's attached on this side
a townhouse maybe sure Staten Island
like like when the boom started
happening and they just threw up its
cookie cutter yeah right love that house
love it they still live there no they
moved to they split their time between
uh Poconos Pennsylvania okay very
familiar with the Pokemon sure a Big
Bass Lake over there they're in there
and then they more and more spending
more time they they uh are in Florida in
The Villages the village is a giant
retirement community there nice that's
[__] awesome that is like the New
York story man yeah always dispatching
for the NTA split your time between the
Poconos and the retirement place in
Florida that's it man what more do they
want that's all you need in this life
man what was the grocery store that your
mom went to Pathmark work Pathmark yeah
Pathmark or there was an Italian place
is closed now called cangiano's on
Highland Boulevard that was probably all
right yeah those they sold like the
pizza dough that they made that morning
if you wanted to go home homemade
raviolis all that stuff that was like
the specialty store yeah that's where
like the labels were like in Italian
because my mother was born in Italy so
when she came over you know her whole
family was here mom's Italian dad's
Irish my dad is half Irish his mother's
mother was born in Italy so there's a
lot of Italian there wow so Brooklyn
Staten Island kid over here oh yeah huh
what was the pizza place that you
weren't growing up uh it was called it
was called ambrosinos now uh it was
called
I don't remember because it's been
ambrosino for like so long okay let's
just all checking out I like it yeah
still in business
make a great hot cherry pepper pie hot
cherry pepper pie they may get the
[__] best man how do you feel about
pineapple on Pizza it's pizza I'll eat
anything I don't care oh my God I'm the
same way what am I gonna do I'm gonna be
that guy
cares about plays ball yeah
yeah you got a slice man yeah I'll take
it huh okay what's your favorite slice
in the city do you have a like a in uh
Manhattan probably oh Manhattan
um
man
that's a great question Joe and Pat's on
the east side
it's pretty good thin crust I've had
that yeah yeah yeah
um but uh you know what I've been
getting into here so that like if I had
to go to a pizza place that'd probably
be where I go in Manhattan but
that Detroit Pizza that that that's been
kicking around holes all right [__] man
yeah sorry I'll eat a whole pie yeah
it's all right I was born in
Wilkes-Barre Pennsylvania and they have
something kind of similar they call it
Sizzle Pie Sizzle Pie it's the same
thing it doesn't really have that cheese
around the outside that Detroit does
yeah that's unbelievable it's just great
I fully switched over to Sicilian that's
like my main Grandma Sicilian or fixes
either way I'm just I'm going Square
yeah yeah I like you're looking for
volume here well then you well New York
Sicilian is like the thick one yeah like
that so I I prefer that but like I gotta
be in the mood for it gotcha it bends
down on uh mcdougall's has a phenomenal
oh really yeah that's a great name
Grandma slice blow your hair back cool
uh what was the family vacations like
growing up what'd you guys do a lot of
um a lot of Pennsylvania like uh Locust
Lake Big Bass Lake renting a house like
a week over there uh you know
splattering of Disney here and there one
trip to Italy but that was like because
my mom's family sure sure like houses
and stuff so we went there uh it was
largely like road trips and stuff like
that pretty basic yeah you know nothing
crazy were you sure people down the
beach or no no more every once in a
while my my aunt's family would get uh a
shore house and occasionally we would go
but no because growing up on Staten
Island I grew up right near the beach
it's not like the same where we would go
down but it wasn't like going to the
beach resort you guys wouldn't swim in
that water would you no not really I
mean you could occasionally and we
certainly did occasionally but now with
currents right no it's more like the
filth yeah the needles yeah it's the
needle medical waste right yeah well the
park that I grew I grew up next right
right next to Great Kills Park and like
spent a lot of my childhood kind of wild
running around there it's giant
multi-acre Park and then in high school
after I just gotten out of my year well
maybe a little after high school they
designated the whole park a super fun
show because they dropped medical waste
and radiation [__] there so the whole
Park's radioactive and you're not even
allowed to go on it anymore and I spent
18 years playing so it's like what the
[__] is
like geez yeah uh what was the first
concert your first concert first concert
was Harry Connick Jr whoa yeah at PNC
how old were you uh
freshman year high school Harry Connick
Jr yeah was that what you were listening
to in high school I was listening to
everything uh but that was the one I had
that I somebody offered me tickets to so
where'd you go would you go with friends
uh you know I don't remember who I went
with it I think it might have been
Murray I think it might have been James
Murray that's pretty crazy to be honest
with you man yeah that was the first
time we've had that I think yeah so
Harry Connick and then then it was
probably the second was
maybe Tom Petty okay all right yeah uh
eventually like while Wu-Tang on Staten
Island you end up going on sure you got
a lot of those but yeah Carrie Connick's
first one wow right not bad
um would you guys do would your mom make
uh sauce on Sunday and do a big dinner
on Sunday and all that stuff better we
would every Sunday we would drive to
Brooklyn to my grandmother's house where
the whole family would get together for
that so your extended family was still
in Brooklyn were you guys the only ones
that lived at Staten Island yeah so my
mom's brother's uh
lived like they didn't stray far from
the okay my grandparents owned this
great they store it down now but it was
this great two-story building with uh
like three lots because my my come from
like um Farmers my grandfather was a
farmer until he came to America so he
bought this property to land that like
now it would probably be worth 70
million dollars not 70 but like yeah
something like 10 million it's like huge
and he just grew he just grew so we had
like wow yeah and all and it was like
nobody lived in that neighborhood unless
they were Italian like and I'm talking
off the boat so the neighborhood would
come together and attend this garden and
everybody would grow their own [__] in
it and uh so it was like and they made
their own wine they had like the whole
thing and so it was like real like Taste
of the Old Country yeah it was like an
Italian compound Little Village so I
grew up over there uh how good was your
grandmother's food awesome
do you make it a lot you used to make it
a lot now I don't make it as much uh uh
but when I but I still got it yeah so I
made about a few months ago I still got
it uh if you had to do a jar since we're
on the topic if you had to do a jar
sauce what are you doing in a pinch
uh this probably I mean I probably
wouldn't get too I wouldn't stick my
nose up too much because if I'm doing if
I'm doing yard sauce maybe like whatever
the Barilla I like pesto I like
store-bought pesto not bad yeah let me
ask you this let's say
chewing a couple of people and you are
making a Jarred sauce yeah are you using
the whole jar and one box of pasta
do you ever not use the whole thing oh
okay
so I vastly I I understand what your
question is right and I think you always
just make the whole thing because what
are you gonna do you're gonna eat that
the next day you're gonna probably eat
it later at night it doesn't make though
you're not gonna put that half a jar
back in there because then when I gotta
go make more I'm not gonna look at the
half jar and be like well how long would
I use that is that still fresh just
[__] use it go out with a bang thank
you sir problem I appreciate it I
disagree you led the witness a little
bit with if it's you and a group of
people the original argument was you're
making a portion of pasta for yourself
right and it's just you okay
Pasto I would do half and half because
okay because you could say nobody said
anything about pesto I don't know you
know just like about red sauces just
letting you know yeah pesto yeah of
course I don't know you don't open that
jar of the red sauce and like there's
that dried up yeah I'm not saying it's
great I'm not saying it but it is you
know but you deserve fresh like don't
you think that about yourself I'll
probably just throw it out and open up a
new one when I go to make the second
batch right it's more of I told you you
got to believe in yourself a little more
well it started on him making a whole
box of pasta for him self as a servant
well it's a pound yeah I'll make a pound
of pasta there you go one night over the
course of a night I can't say it's not
been done
I'm not saying I'm perfect over here
it's not my normal one but I've done it
I've eaten whole pizzas by myself you
guys haven't done that ain't nothing
better than that man yeah you hit a
point of pizza where you're like I can't
do any more and then you're like now you
get your second gear and then there's
like one slice left and you got that
that seven slice shame where you're like
did I eat some slice of pizza and it's
like well [__] it yeah I'm already you
can't put the one slice in there yeah
when you're wet you're wet baby yeah
exactly exactly you drink milk with
dinner growing up
no no never even heard of that would you
ever have milk with uh with pasta or
pizza
it wouldn't occur to me huh I'm not
saying I wouldn't do it but it's never
occurred to me what was on the table for
dinner during the week yeah
it was it was uh it was definitely my
Dad loved Pepsi okay you drink it all
the [__] time so he would buy us Coke
to throw us off the Pepsi what yeah so
there would be like Iris yeah yeah talk
about Italian yeah and he'd be like I
want all I want when I come home is the
Pepsi you guys should have the swill of
Coca-Cola drink the Coke and so a lot of
that yeah Pepsi family ever see a three
liter at the house please
my dad would crush three leaders the old
ones do it like that like just the
ribbon around there yeah yeah did the
mouth on those things yeah huge trying
to hold that as a kid oh man yeah
uh-huh was the light ever off in the
refrigerator growing up
not that I recall no and my brother my
younger brother
uh loved tinkering and stuff so I bet if
the light went out he would have fixed
it he would take care of it yeah I'm
sorry we allowed to eat in your room as
a kid
I don't remember anybody stopping me
okay yeah right were you a shoes off
household
come in the door shoes off you know
there were times where that rule seemed
important and then there were times that
there wasn't so I would say no with
occasionally yes but I took care of my
shoes when I get in anyway do you do
that now yeah and probably kick him off
not not because of just comforter just
yeah I get home I just want to be
comfortable any plastic on any furniture
growing up oh yeah at your house
probably still there I [__] regret it
actually I talked my mom
we had this great orange couch I mean
orange like [__] like the orange you
want it to be you know what I mean like
right bro I'm trying to find some like
pulling the Cool Hand Luke poster okay
bright orange
kind of velvety but text your couch and
my entire life it was covered in plastic
and then when I got to high school I was
like Mom what the [__] like you've had
this couch 20 years like how long are
you gonna save it for and so she I
guilted into taking the plastic off and
then the couch only lasted a few more
years and now now I'm like man why did I
ever that thing would have been great oh
I would I'd be sitting on that couch
today if I could yeah I so regret that
like why did she listen to me was there
one living room or was there a sitting
room and a living room where was the TV
in the house no no no there was there
was like when you walk in the front door
it's almost like like a Railroad Flat
it's like there's the there's the living
room it's just like 13 feet wide yeah
and then the dining room right next to
it but it really that's only like five
feet off the shore and then that goes
into the kitchen kitchen yeah so that
was really everybody just hung out on
that floor there was a basement that we
would eventually get into like when we
were older and stuff like that gotcha
yeah okay did you share a room with your
brothers you guys have your own room no
shared rooms until my older brother
joined the Navy and then me and my
brother my younger brother were able to
get our own room did anybody ever live
in the basement I I live in the basement
you did yeah after a while I moved in
the basement at what age is that uh
probably around High School probably
when I hit high school that's a step of
like I'm out on my own down here yeah a
little bit and I contribute in and out
the window that was always the thing
like because it was ground floor
obviously so I was able to sneak out the
window player Harry Connick Jr yeah
that's right who babysat you as a kid uh
Kim was a uh like a second cousin that I
had an enormous crush on oh that's
always the first love Yeah Kim uh he
also said second cousin by the way yeah
yeah so it was okay
not illegal but frowned upon
I'm not worried about what people are
found out these Italians keep it close
huh yeah yeah family so Kim yeah she was
my babysitter really all right that's
all right uh injuries as a kid
to find kid what age are we talking shop
to high school yeah uh I broke
collarbone skiing I broke uh skied once
in my life okay
oh my God I got I got on it was like I
went up we got you know checked out got
my skis got on the thing went up the
hill got on the slope got about 50 feet
and this like five-year-old kid
cut like who just knows how to ski just
cut me off and I rammed right into a
tree and broke my collar it was like
within 20 minutes the trip was over and
I was sad you're on a trip with the with
the boys Boy Scouts yeah yeah and uh so
then they had to get me home and then
yeah my brother put me in the hospital a
couple times he hit me with a shovel I
needed some
days we were playing in my my
grandfather's uh
farm and he was above me and he had like
a gardening spade and he go and I was
underneath it and he goes like I'm gonna
drop this and I go no and he goes move
I'm gonna drop it and I was like I'm not
moving and then he just dropped it and
it like cleaved my skin down like it
swapped over and uh yeah so I had you
know a couple of bangs here and there
yeah a couple yeah yeah a couple of
banks that's assault yeah okay let's
talk about ladder baby a lot of that
ladder let's talk about taking care of
the ones that take care of you do
yourself a favor gang you don't want to
put this off don't want to leave the
family holding the bag when you croaked
which is probably what I'm gonna do yeah
do yourself a favor get over the ladder
get yourself a little bit of that third
life insurance yeah it's 100 digital no
doctors no needles no paperwork when you
apply for three million in coverage or
less just a few questions about your
health and an application ladder made
Forbes best life insurance list in 2021
and it's easy to see why because they're
out here killing a game yeah no hidden
fees canceled anytime get a full refund
if you cancel in the first 30 days life
insurance gets more expensive as you age
so now is the time to buy I'll repeat
that now is the time to buy go to
latterlife.com to see if you're
instantly approved that's ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com garbage
ladderlife.com
get a pen get a pencil whatever you need
to do that's ladder life
l-a-d-d-e-r life.com slash garbage
letterlife.com
this is all about Factor baby oh baby I
love me is that like two or three of
them at myself to be honest with Ricky
gang do yourself a favor get over the
factor quick and easy they come they're
ready to go they're fresh they're
fantastic you throw them in the
microwave for two minutes and you're
ready to go we're talking top shelf
ingredients here yeah guys I am a huge
fan it's easy peasy uh you can skip I
like the meatballs I just went on
vacation you go on I paused it for a
week set it up you pick out what you
want pause button you get what you want
you get the I'm a shredded taco bowl man
myself shout out to the chili too to
chorizo Chile yeah but they go their way
around some mashed Collies baby with uh
calorie smart and keto options Factor
meals are perfectly portioned to keep
you on track with your goals Factor now
offers 34 meal options per week with
over 3 dozen add-on options like sweet
smoothies juices and so much more uh not
only is Factor cheaper than take out
these meals are ready to heat in just
two minutes and they ain't lying they
are head to factorymeals.com garbage50
and use coach garbage 50 to get 50 off
your first box baby [__] that's code
garbage 50 at factor meals.com garbage50
to get 50 off your first box do it
Factor what were the SAT scores like
not great uh I did I think in the
English side of it I got almost perfect
whoa the math are like
oh yeah it was like you remember a score
it would have been out of sixteen
hundred I don't I don't I I remember
being people being very impressed with
the English and very disappointed
meaty part of the curve I like it hmm
Sports
uh I played soccer as a as I think most
people do when they're kids I played
that for many many years and then when I
got to high school
I was just like I don't wanna I don't
know no Sports in high school no I did
uh uh like um the plays and stuff like
that yeah because that was the only way
you can meet girls because we were an
old boys Catholic High School closer but
when you did when you did plays with the
other the sister schools would come and
that's how you would like that's the
only way you can go with the girls did
you go to prom
I did go to prom yeah yeah yeah you go
with a friend or was you dating somebody
uh your parents oh no that was the sitch
no we got a limo it was me Murray who's
on the show with was in the limo and a
girl that I had been dating for about a
year at that point and we we got a limo
and everything and went like eight
people in a limo with their dates yeah
it's the only thing limos are good for
is proms yeah yeah yeah but there's a
lot of practical use it was fun how
about the pet situation growing up uh I
had rabbits I had uh 9x and Napoleon uh
9x 9x like the old uh uh phone company
they they used to have that because my
dad all right so 9x used to be uh a New
York phone company
well there's a reasonable Atlantic yeah
and this is
got more New York for you so the reason
that he was named 9x is because when I
would go to work with my dad for the
subway they had these um they had these
uh ads for 9x and for some reason their
logo was a rabbit but like a real rabbit
just okay gotcha and so I stole it off
the train when I was a kid well stole my
dad it was just strange I was all I'd
take it
um and uh and I had that on my wall for
years so when I got a rabbit his name
was 9x and then I was leaving this
sounds like a chemical compound yeah
this is P90X this is my cat mayor
Dinkins and then I had Napoleon who was
uh he was I was sorry I I went to the
pet store on new door plane and I got
9xus brown rabbit and we're going to
leave and there was another rabbit in
the corner this little tiny white one
that run to the litter and when I looked
at him he had a deformed paw like his
paw was old jacked up jacked up and and
his birth defect and I was like well
what's gonna happen to that one and they
were like oh you know nobody's adopting
him so I was like well [__] now I have
two rabbits yeah so and they named him
Napoleon for Napoleon because they
always had because he cut his hand like
that and Napoleon was such a sweet
rabbit that we were able to house train
him so like he was able to like live in
the house for not overnight like I'd get
him in the morning yeah then he would
walk around like a dog he would just
hang around with us he never chewed on
wires or anything like that and uh and
he would poop in a cat litter and then
at night we put him back out in the
house this might have been a cat no this
was a cat or a neighborhood yeah uh yeah
so ninex Napoleon had another rabbit
named Rusty uh but growing up that was
it no no cats or dogs no dogs I'd
snagged some lizards but nothing that
like my brothers
when did you have snakes and lizards
well it's only if I caught them like I
didn't go to the store like I lived next
to a lot and they would have these
garden snakes in there so like I had a
fish tank so we would catch the garden
snakes and put them in the tank for like
a day we'll release them the next day
yikes yeah Catchings catching your own
reptiles that Staten Island radioactive
snakes yeah yeah like the Ninja Turtles
now they're out there fighting crime
these guys you know what I'm saying
you're their Splinter
here he goes
who is the dentist growing up uh Raymond
flagello Dr Raymond flagello still in
business alone money on the side yeah uh
was his office in a in a house or was it
in like a professional Center like a
building it was in a it wasn't in a
strip mall it wasn't like a standalone
doctor's office okay that's pretty good
it sounds like you did fillings and
bullet wounds yeah yeah something like
that
no never had business never had braces
no teeth are good teeth are okay they
break they break a lot what do you how
are they now do you do you stay on top
of it a lot are you going no yeah now I
do certainly uh yeah I got I go and but
I got like a couple of fake ones here
and there but for the most part like
they're just broken kind of yellowish
teeth that I've never really gotten
fixed okay okay magazines in the
bathroom as a kid
no no magazines no I was a reader so
there was always a book with me but no
never we didn't have like a magazine
rack or anything like that your reader
you're reading something now yeah I made
a couple of things now
um that's always the smart guy answer
yeah no it's all right so uh you guys
know who uh Rick Rubin is sure of course
he just put out a book on creativity and
I'm reading that and I'm reading a um
book uh you guys Grateful Dead fans at
all so big Steve is like one of their uh
he was like their Roadie for 50 years
and he wrote a book so I'm reading his
book now they're pretty good
a couple non-fictions not bad but I read
a lot of fiction too I don't want to
make it sound like I'm just yeah Harry
Potter guy I read the books yeah yeah
did you enjoy them they were good yeah I
mean I was a little old for it so I
wasn't like this is changing my world
but I was like Swept Away in it but I
got it you know I got white people liked
it okay do you brush your teeth in the
shower no
pee in the shower for sure okay what
kind of soap you use it in there if it's
up to me we're talking an Irish Spring
I know I like good Irish Spring yeah
right yeah I still use bar soap too yeah
me too yeah do you use a loofah or
anything like that no no just bar on
skin bar on skin that's it that's it
yeah wow that was a firefighter you got
time for loofahs masculine any magicians
in the family I wish no no I'm not a
single magician in the family can you
ride a 10 speed while holding a fountain
drink yeah I could do that you can do
that can you ride a 10 speed with no
hands at all
for distances your distances are real
yeah sure the old bat lean back right
it's got to get some good momentum yeah
that center of gravity cooking I like it
uh can you name any of the boats from
The Deadliest Catch
no but I assume that one of them is
called the red crab or the Lusty crab or
something like that it's not a porn yeah
should be the naughty Lobster then I'd
watch it the sexy seal yeah something
like that you play chess
I have played chess but I'm I always
play just enough to learn it and then I
forget okay
um you ever wear uh no anyone in your
family pronounce it refrigerator no
who would do that much of my family
refrigerator refrigerator fridge fridge
yeah refrigerator okay yeah okay instead
of saying thank you do you ever say
cheers or call anybody mate
no I might have done it ironically here
and there I like it you do it if you're
in the UK or will you just still say
thanks buddy or cheers mate if I'm in
the UK I I wanna I want to represent the
United States I don't want to go over
there and start saying their [__] USA
you start slapping people around if I
have to set them I want to
if I have to if I gotta Flex on these
red goats instead throwing Dean gotta
remind them how it went sure hey hey do
you eat fast food now sure you do yeah
excellent what's your fave
that's a great question if I'm if I'm
kicking around Staten Island and I got
to pick something on the way look
there's different situations right sure
lay it out the go-to one is going to be
Wendy's generally for me uh but if I
want that fast food fast food
I'm gonna do McDonald's okay what's the
difference in your head uh Wendy's I
could eat it and like fool myself that
I'm not eating like a raccoon or
something like that like sure
well I'll say you delineated because
there's fast food and then fast food
fast food yeah it's all the same I know
okay I'm not trying but then the the
late night one the guilty one is White
Castle that's where I'm like I will eat
White Castle and you still you're still
banging you still operate like this do
we still have sex no no do you wanna set
it off now you're still eating fast oh
yeah I like the beer it's got less as I
get older and stuff like that but but uh
but I won't turn my nose up on it I know
road trip calls for McNuggets all right
I I understand the I understand the
difference between the fast foods in
your head because to me Chick-fil-A is a
diet fast food I feel like I'm eating at
a restaurant when I get chicken yeah the
problem with Chick-fil-A is like every
time I've been near it there's a line
and I'm right and I'm just like [__] you
I know it's crazy I'm not doing it hire
more people get more registers uh if
you're doing a white have you ever split
a White Castle crave case between you
and one other person
oh God yeah when I was younger for sure
yeah that's like 24 right so what that's
30 I think
I mean if you told me if you if the
question was have I ever eaten 15 White
Castles over the course of one night
yeah
for sure numbers yeah he ain't no
[__] bubble gumer no huh ever been
bitten by a dog
yes but not not much yeah
Jesus Christ this guy goes [__] full
bore yeah uh do you sneak snacks into a
movie theater
uh oh God snacks sandwiches uh really
bottles of wine yeah sure yeah Brave
case yeah we'll do a bottle of wine a
little Ant-Man and a Chianti yeah I'll
do uh when you open it in there like
zero shame uh why does this screw off
like Jameson I'll bring in uh that's
just a good old-fashioned gentleman
right I once took the like there was a
true TV executive's uh back when they
had Executives and uh we went to go see
the new Star Wars movie and I bought a
bottle of Jameson and I got them all ham
like the [__] best yeah shine right
here guys
it was cool they were good people uh but
yeah I like it when I was shooting at
the cruise baby yeah that's it
uh yeah I think it's my right to bring
like a a sandwich into a sandwich what
kind of sandwich we taught like
something smell like or like no you
don't want to do like a fish or anything
like that I like it to me just kind of
roast beef some lettuce some some cheese
okay don't be an animal about it sure
yeah huh where are you shopping now
who's doing the grocery shopping
no it's really the pandemic completely
put that over to like it's a delivery
yeah it gets delivered it's [__] what
a five dollar delivery fee it's like I
respect it all right doing well I agree
once you start doing that you go why
would I shop any other way yeah it's
crazy and my friend had a good theory he
was saying like yeah but like the money
that you're spending on the delivery fee
which is again he's like you you would
impulse buy that if you went to the
supermarket you'd be like oh I could
have some biscuits that's also true yeah
right whereas when you just order you're
just very yeah you're lean and mean baby
yeah how do you feel about the Funyun
I don't hold anything against the phone
yeah it's not something I reach for
political answer yeah but I'm not gonna
I wouldn't look at somebody eating a
Funyun and being like you know what's
wrong with you do you know anybody named
Richie
yeah okay yeah
do you have any aunts or uncles that you
don't call by their first name for
example like Aunt hoodie or Uncle no
it's always Uncle Sal Uncle Mike yeah
okay Uncle we got an Uncle Mike Uncle
Mike Uncle Sal yeah shout out Uncle
Mike's are big shout out to my Uncle
Mike everybody's got one for some reason
I think he's pretty clean uh did your
did you or your parents ever buy
Products off TV Shamwell Slap Chop Thigh
Master no again it might have been an
ironic purchase at some point but now as
a rule now you have a pizza cutter in
the house growing up
yeah for sure is that one now yeah have
one now it's it's shaped like um the USS
Enterprise and the the the saucer the
ship the Enterprise the saucer is the
pizza I spoke too soon yeah all right
yeah
um ever own any inflatable furniture
they were big back in the day like a
chair I had an air mattress uh
uh that I got some use out of recently
but yeah it's not too shabby ever wear
colored contacts
for work sure okay part-time as a cat
yeah yeah
anybody in the family ever claim to see
UFO
no anyone in your family still have an
AOL email address yes
yes no okay
how do you feel about frozen pizza
give me a tombstone I'll take a shout
out to a tombstone all right all right
is that your go-to if you're going to
buy one if I'm good well I know
DiGiorno's is another good one but
yeah so it's one of those two okay I
feel like you don't see Tombstone that
much you know which is why when I see it
I grab it yeah smart man I like you a
little bit about the house now yeah
um
in the kitchen yeah what's the
refrigerator we're talking sub Z Viking
what are we looking at no Samsung
Samsung yeah stainless steel uh
stainless steel it's got the the screen
in it that plays Spotify and stuff like
that yeah you hit a button and you can
see the inside of your fridge but for
the most use that is that practical it
is I use I use that thing I mean it was
I mean the music I get or whatever the
music I see through never use it never
use it yeah what I do is I but like
because you put wallpaper on it I'll
just put pictures of my cats like and
stuff like that so how many cats uh I
have two cats I had three one recently
passed away wow I'm sorry already yeah
thank you he's great just cats any dogs
no I would I love dogs but I just
because we travel so much I can't really
yeah what are your cats names uh Chessie
and Brooklyn are them now and Benjamin
is the one that recently passed away
it's all very classic yeah it's not too
bad yeah keep the butter in the fridge
you keep it on the counter in the fridge
I yeah I mean the cats would probably
lick it if I left it on the counter
you know get
out I implied there would be a dish
there yeah you never know if you're
buying if you're buying a six-pack for
the house yeah uh and you put in the
fridge you take it out like say you buy
bottles will you take it out of the
cardboard or just put the cardboard
right in uh I'll take it out of the
cardboard I think damn I believe I do
that yeah I mean I was really thrown by
that sweatshirt too I thought you're
gonna be dead to rights trash but it's
not too bad can you whistle with your
fingers no that's why you got the slide
whistle yeah that's true well you wear
sneakers out of the store
I mean what happened to my shoes like
you were almost you were in such a bad
point where you're like buddy you got to
throw these out I'm wearing these out or
wear them where the new ones at and put
the old ones in the Box no I haven't
done that I wouldn't not do it but I
haven't okay goddamn gentlemen ever get
a haircut on vacation
maybe on a cruise ship
okay for work or you were there on
vacation and oh so they're there for
work okay we had a cruise and I got a
touch up on the cruise I'll give you
that you're working what is that from
the is that from the hair stylist or is
that they have a barber shop on this
yeah they have a barber shop I just go
down and if I really yeah and if I've
never even thought about that yeah it's
like I just need to touch up or if I've
been in Vegas or something like that
like I might have been like sure trim me
up go trim me up yeah okay you have a
go-to karaoke song
no but if I did it would probably be
uh Islands in the Stream
or if I was singing with someone or I
was doing a Duo maybe Free Falling if
it's just me all right yeah pretty good
you ever have a manicure or a pedicure
never one that I paid for like sometimes
you get like these free like when you
when you go to events they're like and
downstairs we have like a lounge where
you can get it so then I might do it but
I never paid for what kind of event is
that I don't know what that is well
they'll have like just meaning you're
doing way cooler [__] than I am yeah
it's like because what they'll be like
is like Hey we're doing a press thing
and like so they fly you out to the
middle of nowhere for a few days yeah
like and now you do just do these
interviews all days or me to add add
execs to like sell ads for your show or
whatever and they'll pamper you a little
bit and they'll be they'll give you like
here's 300 000 credit for the thing and
if you don't use it you lose it so um
you know that's a trashy phrase but I
respect it yeah use it you lose it baby
when was your last massage you get
massages not a massage guy they very
rarely do anything for me I have done
them uh on a vacation every once in a
while but that's usually if the person
I'm with would want one and then like a
couple's thing but gotcha I would never
go get one on my own what was uh what
was the last vacation
oh [__] uh
uh last year I went to Key West okay
with a couple of uh with uh oh my buddy
jiggy's bachelor party I went to Key
West I know okay yeah yeah okay this is
rocket money baby this is saving you
money what do you get money he's
shooting to the Moon to save you money
everybody's got a bunch of subscriptions
I just got banged out with an MLB
package some of you don't even know and
I didn't even know I had 150 bucks they
want for the season Harper's not even
playing until the All-Star Game give me
a break gang do yourself a favor they
know what subscriptions you have you can
cancel them at any time they're
absolutely fantastic they're trying to
save you a little bit of cash yeah uh
and you can even find out you might be
getting double charged with sometimes
sometimes the [__] sign up twice they
got your back that's what rocket money
does the cancel subscription you just
press cancel and Rocket money takes care
of the rest it's easy peasy lemon
squeezy get rid of unuseful uh
subscriptions with rocket money now go
to rocketmoney.com garbage seriously
could save you hundreds of dollars per
year and who don't need a couple hundo
any old pocket that's rocketmoney.com
garbage cancel your unnecessary
subscriptions right now at
rocketmoney.com garbage do it it now
back to the show back to the show kids
bulletproof
breakfast in bed well I wouldn't get out
of bed to go get breakfast and bring
bring them back to bed that seems weird
like once I'm out I'm out okay but
breakfast in front of a TV immediately
after getting out of bed sure okay yeah
go sign that when you're at the house
will you eat your meals at the kitchen
table or will you take it and sit down
at the couch and watch TV
both I will probably
probably steps a lot on the couch a lot
happens on the couch but there's no
kitchen table in the kitchen
um there's like a kitchen dining room
thing where I live now uh but we will
just for some reason just stand around
the house eating just just eat in the
kitchen and standing and eating I don't
know why but we do it you ever have a
quail egg
maybe in England once but no I don't
think so maybe in England
if you are watching TV and eating do you
have like a go-to eating show like I
always watch The Simpsons when I eat no
I I it's always just backlog stuff you
know what I mean like what do I gotta
watch what do I got to see there's no I
watch a lot of um
you watch Toast of London you ever hear
of this show oh [__] I'm about to open
your world man it is one of my favorite
shows so you know who Matt Berry is
right he's on what we do in the shadows
he plays Lazlo sure now he'd made this
show in the UK called Toast of London uh
which is about this washed up British
actor uh and his adventures in the
theater and it's like his name's Stephen
toast and it's so [__] funny like
it's totally surreal like kind of a mean
sense of humor like British [__] it's on
britbox right now uh you know I'm not
here to do an advertising for bird box
but yeah it was on Netflix and I watched
the [__] out of a Netflix and Netflix
pulled it so I bought the DVDs from the
UK and then made my Xbox like zone two
you know and I was watching on that but
britbox just launched it and it's so
[__] it's all watched a lot of toast
to London while I'm eating I had
wrestling yeah you want to see garbage I
watch a lot of pro wrestling really
there you go still oh still yeah really
who's your favorite wrestler now
oh that's so rough I mean Chris Jericho
is always for me like
just some of the best of the I mean
there's so much talent out there now who
is your favorite of all time Rowdy Roddy
Piper shout out to the piper yeah who
dabbled in comedy later in the yeah did
some Always Sunny it was really funny
yeah he was always hanging out at the
comedy store but they live I mean you
guys saw they live of course right you
know so they live you so oh have you
heard if they live yeah yeah uh Alien
movie The Alien movie yeah yeah yeah
they live yeah so it's about Roddy Piper
plays a a like a transient um whatever
he's oh he's running around with the
shotgun yeah he's got the sunglasses
that lets him see the aliens and I
re-watched it lately recently and I was
like [__] it holds up man it's so good
huh have you ever been to a live WWE
event where you made your own sign not
where I've made my own sign but I've
been to many Live Events yeah I feel
like that's the Demar that's the
demarcation zone is like if you're the
Sign Guy at the W you're like I don't
know I don't want to look down on those
signs they're so much fun man they're
talking some good [__] yeah I took a
sign to WC by WCW back in like you know
yeah it's probably 97 or something about
on Long Island they used to go they used
to do the uh the Long Island what do
they call it where the island is played
they just tore it down yeah but I saw
WCW the place you were just at for the
no I was at the new one no the new
USBs that's a nice uh that's a nice
piece of property I haven't been there
yet we're going out there we're playing
there soon that's crazy I went for the
UFC and you're playing there that's sick
huh will you take your shoes off on a
plane
if yeah I'll do that not all the time
normally I'll keep them on but I can't
pretend that I've never taken my shoes
off sure if it's a long flight if we're
going to La and like there's one of
those bed ones that fold out and stuff
the beds come on yeah you're up front
you're flying first class I gotta go up
front you're up front I usually go up
front yeah yeah it's just uh it's just
easier getting on and off the plane sure
yeah of course I'm a big up front guy
myself yeah we love it
um will you bring food on a plane
if I buy it in the airport and I'm not
finished yeah but I'd like to finish
where I get on the plane of those people
that like are eating like a baked potato
on the plane what are you guys doing you
got any shower cream up there yeah uh
well you get cash back when you're
making a purchase at like CVS or so or
Duane Reade no I I can't say I've never
done it but I think generally it's not a
it's not a practice habit okay when you
when you were flying and you were in the
back of the plane yeah probably a while
ago would you would you recline the seat
there's a price where you're like I'm
not doing it like you know what I mean
like sure where you're like I'm sorry
it's like it's just crazy yeah yeah uh
would I recline the seat I mean it
doesn't matter in that seat go like see
it doesn't go back a whole bunch yeah do
you do it do you do it now if it's not a
lay down you know I I probably tend not
to but not
to be considerate it's normally just
because I'm I'm comfortable yeah yeah
gotcha you open your eyes under water in
the pool
salt water pool yes
chlorine no real I figured that'd be the
other way around but I guess the
chemicals are bad yeah it's the
chemicals that give you the red eye and
stuff like that do you have a pool I do
salt water yeah gentlemen jacuzzi no
although
this might put me on the bad side of
list we had a a party a barbecue last
summer and I went on Amazon and I got an
inflatable hot tub and I said it but and
I [__] did it to be funny but
everybody [__] loved it yeah man it
was unbelievable it was so big it was
like
it's like an above ground pool and I
took the pool the you know like when
your pool covers got to have a pump to
pump the water out when it rains I took
that pump and I put it in the pool and I
filled the hot tub with the warm already
warm stuff already warm salt water so it
was like [__] everybody loved it man
that's great and then I returned it when
I was done this guy's trash this guy is
trash when you were killing it what are
you talking about right I never I didn't
come here claiming not to be trash dude
dude talk about Ace in the [__] the
English portion and then yeah this is
yeah
there you go this guy's about to get it
too
toaster London yeah trust me you and
your hoity-toity shows ain't shaking
that way oh you watch toast it's not a
whole YouTube you guys are gonna [__]
love it I like it
um anyone in your family get married at
the courthouse no okay
uh uh have you ever had a hot dog in a
hamburger roll
no never no I've hadn't been maybe in
like white bread like folded over here
but not a hamburger roll have you ever
saved a Crown Royal bag
no no although I could see why people
would yeah do you keep the boxes of
things like do you still have uh your
Xbox box or your PlayStation box box for
repeating if you get an appliance yeah
an appliance will go away like for a
while I was keeping Apple products and
then I was like why am I doing this
those boxes feel fancy yeah I feel like
you can throw them away right away yeah
but for the most part I think that I
will I don't know I mean like I buy
figurines like uh not quite that but
sure so I'll play with that yeah like
that Boba Fett came in a box I would
probably put that box up in the attic
because sure yeah just in case the
Collectibles what's going on with the
figurines what are we talking about here
you have a collection many of uh well
I'm a huge combo guy okay um so when I
was a kid I was buying like the figures
and stuff like that uh the statues not
so much action figures not the mezco
uh not not the bigger ones you mean yeah
those are so yeah I got a couple of
those because then people give them to
you as gifts and stuff like that I have
a super I have a Christopher Superman
one and it looks exactly yeah it's like
Sideshow Collectibles or something not
my buddy Greg comedian Greg Stone uh is
a big collector and he he gave me that
one yeah it's wild I I love I have ton
of Superman it's my favorite so I have a
ton of Superman stuff okay stuff like
that comic book collection like uh well
it's pretty big but a few years ago I
switched to digital because I was I just
the bot I mean I have so many of those
long boxes and and I started collecting
in the 90s so it's worth absolutely
nothing you know it's all like the worst
Comics but you got spawn three yeah
exactly I'm like all right I guess
um but uh so I still have in the Attic
uh in in my attic but I read digital now
it's just a lot easier do you have
anything that that is of super value you
got anything real old school I do have a
couple of things I have uh because I was
going to San Diego Comic-Con in the 90s
before it was like yeah yeah and uh I
used to be able to buy animation cells
from Batman the anime series for like 10
bucks and I bought uh there was a
Superman comic called Superman for all
seasons and uh it's gorgeous it's
watercolor every page is a watercolor
painting and I there's this two-page
spread uh the first time you see
Superman flying down with Lois and Lex
Luthor standing down there looking them
all [__] pissed and I bought those
both those pages and it's like it's a
watercolor background and then like a
clear
being with the line work on it so it's
like the line work goes over it's
gorgeous and I bought them both for 50
bucks for both of them and they're
probably worth like 20 grand now
20 grand [__] but I you know I'm not
gonna what am I you know I have that I
have a you know preacher the comic
preacher okay so my buddy Scott Moser
bought me uh I don't know how well you
know the comic but in when he finds out
Cassidy's a vampire he gets stabbed in
the eye in a in a fight in the parking
lot I have the page the artwork or the
original page with the knife in his eye
and Custer going like going well holy
[__] of you all right I have that and
Moshe gave that to me I don't even know
what that's worth yeah I have to be
their nerd translator sometime that's
sick that he hasn't yeah that's like
that's like
yeah it's like the original artwork that
Steve Dylan did I I have a bunch of that
uh like artwork and stuff like that
obviously yeah pretty good man pretty
good hmm that's not even trashy that's
clear that's clear if you have a room
where you have all this stuff showcased
and stuff uh not it's more like
dispersed about the house but but I have
a a basement that I have some pinball
machines and I keep a lot of like a
DeLorean uh like a one six Back to the
Future DeLorean I have stuff down there
that's a little bit you know display
yeah what are you whipping around in
what's what what's what's the car uh
2018 Jeep Wrangler yeah okay it's a Jeep
thing yeah I had a Wrangler before that
I had a 2014 but the guys blew it up on
the TV show
I got a new one yeah I
that's the only car really yeah well no
that's not true uh I have we drove in
the Impractical Jokers movie in 1989
Crown Vic that we drove in the movie
when the movie ended I bought the car so
I have that in storage I pulled that up
damn you got it crazy do you still own a
Crown Vic oh dude let me tell you I
drive them around Manhattan it is a
[__] pest the thing's a boat guy's
over 40 are it's like I'm driving a
Maserati
they can't like homeless people will
come up and be like I worked on this
[__] back in the 80s like and it's like
it's [__] awesome women don't even
see the car yeah women are like I'm like
I'm just driving in the Superman logo on
this side get out of the way yeah
they're like get this [__] but men like
love the [__] car and like when I go
parking in like garages because you go
like you'll go to like a parking garage
in New York City and it's like always
like the guy at the front will park a
Porsche or Rolls-Royce those guys give
the 20 right to like Park up there so
whenever I drive the Crown Vic in the
city I give the guy 20. and I'm like I
want you to what I'm saying right next
to that [__] Rolls Royce
I have these pictures of the of the
Crown Vic next to all these expensive
cars because I'm like [__] these guys I
can't I respect this guy's uh as a
gentleman yeah that's all right I'm
pretty good I mean all right you know
he's walks in both worlds a little bit
like the day Walker you are pretty
classy gentleman I would say it's right
down the middle I mean he did return up
a inflatable hot tub after he used it
but that was for a joke I only bought it
for a joke but the returned was serious
oh what am I gonna spend 600 bucks on a
joke yeah you're an Impractical Joker no
yeah but they're Amazon
they got billions they get [__]
repurpose that
are you an orange juice guy I I I don't
go for it but I I will have it you like
Pulp I love pulp yeah all right have you
ever had a voicemail where you're like a
fake one where you're like hello hello
hello I'm not here no I I hate that okay
yeah all right you ever sing into the
answering machine no no we didn't have
an answer ever named the pets in a
voicemail like you've reached Brian and
I would though I probably would and
Verizon yeah I can't say I wouldn't do
that but I haven't have you ever gotten
an autograph from someone oh God yeah uh
geez who do I have
well
yeah maybe when I was younger wrestlers
and stuff like that it's like that's
good that's okay yeah like like you
never really got oh uh yes I actually
bought it uh online you know Chuck
barris's so you you know uh the gong
show of course Confessions of a
dangerous mind so his book is one of my
CIA Contract Killer do you ever hear
this story okay so Chuck Barris yes
created The Gong Show and he was a host
of The Gong Show and he was he created
The Dating Game he's a Madman right and
he wrote a book called confessions of
the dangerous mind which was an
autobiography in which he claimed that
the entire time he was making TV shows
he was really a Hitman for the CIA and
all the places that he went to shoot his
TV show were hits that he had to do and
the book is it's magnificent he never
breaks he's always he says it and he
went to his grave claiming that it was
all true it was all true yeah so I
bought uh I bought uh some signed stuff
from him the movie's great too Cleveland
directed it the movie's great phenomenal
yeah Sam Rockwell great yeah brilliant
in it I got one how many suits do you
own
probably
three okay just collected over the years
but I mean none of them are newer than
10 years old so what are we talking
about anything Armani anything like that
no Macy's whatever yeah you know you own
a tuxedo no you know how to tie a tie I
know how to do uh well I went to a
Catholic boys high school so yeah gotcha
okay who's cutting the hair now
uh there's a guy named Max that works in
Brooklyn at Men's best haircut but I've
kind of stopped getting haircuts for a
while I had my hair really short for you
almost like you yeah for the past five
years and uh I'm just like yeah maybe
I'll grow it out a little bit I mean
someone who's trim
is clean no that's just no no that's
just that's no haircut for four or five
months what yeah damn it's pretty good I
think jeans this guy is class I know all
right thank you it doesn't need a
haircut
all right last question oh here we go
Miracle Whip or Hellman's mayonnaise
mayonnaise I'm not a mayonnaise guy I
will not I will have a smear of it on a
sandwich but I'm not a male guy and what
would the sandwich be if you're making a
sandwich at the house what would it be I
wish it wasn't but it'd probably be
roast beef yeah
I try and eat less and less because I
always I can never eat it without
thinking about the poor animal so I'm
trying to like get out of it are you
trying to stay you're trying to stay
away from meat a little bit I am I'm
trying to be easy on myself and just
reduce it rather than being like I'm
never really strict yeah yeah so I'm
trying to reduce it um I watched this
video of um this guy goes and there's
tons of videos out there like this this
guy goes to a field and he puts down a
chair it's just a field and uh he starts
playing a violin yes one by one these
[__] cows come from nowhere and by
the end of it there's 20 cows around
them just listening to the music and
they you see it they they see it and
they just come and listen to this guy
play violin and I'm like I can't [__]
eat these things anymore yeah these guys
are showing up at concerts man like they
love the music so you know I'm trying to
sell them balloons too yeah until that
creep case comes called yeah right yeah
I don't know so I'm trying to cut back
but I'm also trying to be realistic
about it oh
[__] wait so at the end of it hold on
so at the end of it it's just you just
pass judgment if I'm garbage enough yeah
I mean you don't have to be so harsh
past judgment it's a harsh way to put it
we use a very science we said you were
classy I thought this is all leading to
something it's all leading to like I'll
take it so so wait I'm officially not
garbage you're officially not garbage
man you're right I'll I'll you're a
gentleman you got me with the violin
I'll say you're a gentleman with some
garbage Tendencies okay wow I mean do I
get like a plaque or something like that
for not being garbage I I felt for sure
I was gonna come here and be garbage
we'll mail it to you oh we just did an
hour-long intro that's what I thought
just vamping
oh man I wasn't I didn't even think I
was funny or entertaining
oh fantastic all right no it was great
man thank you so much thank you easy
peasy
ladies and gentlemen Mr Brian Quinn
thank you thank you appreciate it
let the cows start coming
a bunch of raccoons start walking in
here what the [__] oh man you got
anything you want to hit the folks up
there with uh yeah come see us on tour
the Impractical Jokers we're live on
tour we're playing the New York area uh
we're doing Prudential Center in a
couple of weeks come on Amazing come see
us on tour and uh every Thursday night
new episodes of season 10 Impractical
Jokers are airing on True TV and TBS my
man unbelievable check that out
congratulations yeah thanks so much guys
this was a lot of fun unreal thank you
Kippy what do you got for him we're all
over the road as well shows are selling
out we're adding some and some markets
get those tickies now before they're
gone thank you so much gang come see us
we love you and we'll see you next week
peace